the gallows is a found-footage horror
film and it's about a student play from
1993 in which a kid was unfortunately
killed 20 years later the school board
has decided to do this play again and
one student involved with the play does
not want to take part in it but he has
to because it's a mandatory class he
sneaks in with some of his friends one
night to try to destroy the set and ruin
the place so he doesn't have to do it
then everyone gets inexplicably trapped
in this school and weird stuff starts
happening that seems to have some sort
of connection with that 1993 original
play in which the kid was killed and of
course they film all of it found footage
horror at one point in time was an
original concept when a Blair Witch
Project came out tons of people were
afraid they thought it was real a lot of
people in my school legitimately thought
that was a real movie when it came out
but ever since paranormal activity made
so much money on such a tight budget
found footage is now an extremely
popular thing with Studios because they
can look at something and say hey this
script is in a contained area a school
there's barely any characters in it
there's like four actors we have to hire
we don't really have to worry about
lighting because all the electricity is
going to be on the school and they'll
just use their flashlights and night
vision and we can probably make this
movie for like a hundred dollars and
make a lot of money back because that's
what these studios are doing nowadays
they don't always seem to look so
closely at that script anymore as they
do the bank return that being said the
gallows is better in some ways than some
found footage horror films I've seen
recently in particular the location when
I was in fifth grade I wrote a story
called midnight tag it was about a group
of kids who got trapped in a school and
were followed around by a hooded cloaked
figure that continued to mess with them
which is exactly what happens in this
movie so if I had released my writings
from fifth grade to the public I would
be suing somebody right now but I didn't
so there's two things to say about that
number one
the location is awesome it's by far the
best part of this movie they
accomplished a lot of chilling
atmosphere with this deserted school in
the middle of the night it really was
effective and I like that because when I
was in fifth grade I wrote a very
similar story so I obviously liked the
location and the use of that location
number two I wrote it in fifth grade
the writing in this movie is atrocious
it's absolutely atrocious to twist at
the end of the film I won't spoil it for
you but it's kind of interesting when
you first see it and then when you start
to think about it you realize that the
entire film doesn't make sense now it's
one of those twists where when you first
see it you're like oh that's kind of
neat that's interesting wait a second
that doesn't make any sense in
retrospect when you think about the
entire film you just saw after
experiencing the ending nothing fits
anymore there are so many plot holes
let's talk a little bit about the
characters ha ha characters fuck the
movie starts out with the most
insufferable
rude annoying asshole holding the camera
for 30 minutes he follows students
around making fun of them he throws
footballs at unpopular kids he zooms in
on girls
and talks about how ugly they are
there's a point where funny and
insulting meet you have to always be in
that gray area in the middle
this guy launches over to just being a
dick bag and I understand that was the
point of the filmmakers they were
introducing you to the most rude person
on planet earth and you just want this
person to go away and they want you to
feel that way so that when the shit goes
down you're like yeah get that guy he's
annoying it just went on and on and on I
was like this is the exact kind of kid I
hated when I was in school I don't want
to be in the company this douche bag
anymore get him out of here also there
is not a school board on earth that
would hold the same play again that a
child accidentally died while performing
before now besides the location being
really effective the other idea this
film had that was really clever I liked
was they have two kids they both have
two cameras and they will switch back
and forth between these cameras to let
you know things that happened while the
kids separate that was a really
interesting idea and I really thought
that added something to the movie
because like one kid would be separated
you hear all these noises you're like oh
my gosh what's happening to him you
don't find out until a few minutes later
when they then cut to that kids camera
you realize it's about five minutes in
the past from what you've already
witnessed and you get to see what
happened to him all those noises you see
that play out that's a really good idea
and that's by far the best thing that
gallows has to offer in regards to a
filmmaking perspective the majority of
this movie is awaiting
gigantic jump-scare loud noise sound
effect there is no actual tension that's
build up in this film it's what I talked
about in my video
the problem with horror movies today
let's talk about a movie called rear
window directed by Alfred Hitchcock one
of the best films ever made real tension
was developed throughout this movie
because you're watching someone
witnessed someone across the street and
you're like something's about to happen
and you just feel that sense throughout
the entire film that something really
terrible is going to happen and as it
builds and builds you just feel the
weight the heat the tension of that
situation
nowadays with these cheaply made horror
films there is no actual tension
developed in the film the only tension
you have is awaiting that extremely loud
noise that's going to pierce through
your ears in 7.1 Dolby Digital surround
sound that's not scary it's a loud noise
and 75% of time in this film it's one of
their friends scaring them or they shut
a door really loudly or somebody walked
in a room really fast all my thoughts on
this were confirmed to me when I heard
the girl sitting behind me whisper to
her friend here it comes when there was
an obvious noise about to happen when
everything goes silent for a second you
know they're about to play some loud
music these modern horror films nowadays
they have a clever idea
this past with this play it's creepy you
know you're in this school it's deserted
that is creepy you're finding these
strange things everywhere creepy creepy
creepy that works the atmosphere in the
movie works but this found footage
shaky-cam stuff with flashlights and
high school kids making asshole
douchebag comments every other second
doesn't work it annoys the shit out of
you and the jump scare element needs to
stop if you want to use a jump scare in
the movie do it like the insidious films
have those loud noise is actually
accompanying something that is supposed
to be startling have it be in an actual
film that has a musical score not a
found footage film with no musical score
that for some reason has these loud
jump-scare musical elements all of a
sudden 50 times throughout the movie I'm
tired of the way horror films are
directed nowadays and this is a prime
example of what I've been talking about
for the past few years I'm gonna give
the gallows a d-plus
something I am really excited to tell
you guys about though is that I'm gonna
be at San Diego comic-con I have never
been to a comic-con in my entire life
I've never been on a panel or part of a
panel ever but I get to go on to this
time I am so honored and so privileged I
am so excited I'm going to be on the
masters of the web panel with John
Campea Mark Ellis Jon Schnepp Gray Drake
Andy signor and my buddy Jeremy John's
it's going to be a lot of fun I'm also
going to be on a panel with screen
junkies doing a live movie fights
episode I really hope you guys come it's
going to be on Friday both of those are
on Friday you can find some information
on my official Facebook I posted about
the Masters of the web panel if you want
to go to that link which I've left in
the description below
I'm so excited guys and I hope to see
some of you there and meet some of you
guys that's what I'm really excited
about is meeting some of you guys so
hopefully I can do that thank you so
much as always for watching and if you
like this you can click right here and
get stuck mine eyes
you